[Applaudissements]
c'était le match des grands jours à
ouille pour ce 7e tour de la Coupe de
France le club local pensionnaire de R1
recevait les professionnels d'Angers ce
samedi 18 novembre une équipe qui évolue
en Ligue 2 après 45 minutes très
équilibré sur un terrain humide ce sont
finalement les visiteurs qui ouvrent le
score grâce à lois Dioni 1-0 ce sera le
score à la pause ça manquait un peu de
d'intensité on jouait pas les coups à
fond mais des jeux égal et euh on prend
un but
euh qui pas forcément mérité sur une une
erreur d'appréciation mais c'est les
détails qui qui compte à ce niveau-là la
première période était une période de
qualité euh voilà on a réussi à jouer au
ballon à à produire du jeu et c'était
intéressant à se procurer quelques
situations dangereuses en seconde
période ouille n'abdique pas tant
d'égaliser se procure des situations
mais ce sont finalement les enevins qui
font le break à la 90e minute suite à ce
penalty 2 à0 la logique a été respectée
ce samedi sur cette pelouse ivinoise
aujourd'hui le petit pousser ne
renversera pas un gros on peut être fier
de ce qu'on a ce qu'on a fait on joue
contre une division qui a 5 niveaux
auudessus du autre je m'attendais à une
victoire je m'attendais une victoire peu
importe l'adversaire encore une fois je
le dis sur un match il peut tout se
passer c'est aussi le cherme de la la
Coupe de France les les conditions nous
étaient favorables après voilà tout est
dans l'intensité dans le réalisme
tactiquement techniquement c'est évident
que il y a une classe d'écart et et et
ça se voit en tout cas lorsque nous
sommes sur le terrain maintenant
aujourd'hui avec de la volonté avec
plein de choses on a réussi à combler
ces petits manques et à montrer que sur
90 minutes on peut essayer de rivaliser
ou devra maintenant se reconcentrer sur
le championnat de R1 les ivinois
occupent pour l'instant la 9e place du
classement après 6 journées disputé